hello everybody thank you so much for
coming we're very grateful for your
presence um at this lecture this
afternoon I'm Kathy rup I'm the director
of the Council on E stage and studies
and we will be seeing a short video um
that Professor Eric green will tell you
about as well um he will be giving the
introduction of our honor
guest thank you Kathy for introducing
the introducer as it were uh thank you
all uh for coming as Kathy said I'm uh
Eric Ken I teach in the department of
religious studies uh focusing on
Buddhism in uh China one of a couple
faculty there in the area of Buddhist
studies um it's my great pleasure today
to uh introduce our uh speaker at the
venerable jungmok uh to ensure uh our
time is used efficiently I'm just going
to say a few words before we get started
um the venerable uh JM stands as one of
the most eminent senior female Buddhist
monastics in South Korea today she was
ordained in 1978 uh and oh sorry 1976
excuse me uh and completed her
bachelor's degree uh in Zen studies and
then a master's degree in social work
from uh donuk uh University uh which is
also the institution where my colleague
Professor wansuk Kim uh had his
undergraduate degree uh the venerable uh
jungmok has served as a Buddhist
chaplain at the soul National University
Hospital and in 1997 founded the small
love Foundation which offers uh
financial support to families with
children battling uh cancer she
currently serves as the abbis of the
jongok temple in central uh Soul uh
she's renowned for her pioneering work
in Buddhist media uh and initiated a
daily radio program with the Buddhist
Broadcasting Service in 1990 uh and
later established the unaa Broadcasting
Service which is a YouTube channel with
nearly a quarter million subscribers uh
she was recently recognized as one of
the most influential female Buddhist
monastics in South Korea today um she's
the author of several best-selling books
written in Korean uh including uh and
I'm I'm not sure where these
translations of the titles came from but
I'm sure they're they're very accurate
though the snail is snow slow it is
never late uh the more you empty
yourself the more you have and even
flowers have to make an effort to bloom
she's today going to share um um her
life story with us and her talk will be
translated by one of our ma students uh
Yono who is around somewhere
she she who'll come down whenn that
times excellent and following the
presentation um there'll be lots of time
I hope uh for your questions um I before
we commence with the main activity I
want to just express my gratitude to the
uh Council uh staff on the Council of
East Asian studies for all their efforts
uh in making this possible and uh before
we welcome the venerable jungmok we are
going to watch a short two-minute video
that highlights on some aspects of her
work which I think will be queued
somehow miraculously now there we go
[Music]
for
fore
[Music]
so
[Applause]
you put they don't have to take it
Hello nice to meet
you hello
everyone
who made this video this is my first
time seeing
[Music]
it actually I'm not as great as the
video makes me
seem I'm so happy to be here here this
is the first time in my life that I've
been invited to an American
University so it's a very exciting time
for me from the time I was invit a year
ago until now I've been so excited and
looking forward to meeting all of you
and now I finally meeting you
all I don't speak English very well I
want to Green you in English I practiced
a few
lines so I decided to speak in Korean
and have some someone translate for
me I'll talk to you in Korean from now
on
yeah people actually call me the mother
of healing in
Korea I'm not even married and I've
never had a
child do I look like a
[Laughter]
mother for a long time I've wondered why
people call me the mother of
healing even when I was 30 a 50-year-old
man once called me
mother
he was crying and he ran into my arms
like a young
child I hear some people call Yale
University with its 300-year history the
mother of American
universities what does mother mean to
all forms of
life
mothers are people we can truly trust
trust the most after being born into
this
world moms are a symbol of our faith in
world people want to be protected from a
fearful
world
everyone wants to rely on someone and be
cared
for I think people wanted to find that
sort of trust and Care in
Me Maybe I reminded them of their
mothers that is probably why they called
me
mother
in that respect I am very thankful for
that
title I feel very very
grateful but I too feel fear
sometimes and I have one particular
experience with
fear
in 1981 before most of the students here
were even
born I love to practice deep in the
mountains and I was 21 years old at the
time the temple was a small shabby cabin
deep in the mountains in the country
side I knew a senior monk there so I set
off for it with my friend a fellow Monk
and the way to that Temple was
incredibly
rough there were no roads and we had to
go through a thick forest and cross a
Deep
River
do you know those rivers with strong
churning Waters like a Whirlpool we had
to cross that to get to the
Hermitage so I took off my shoes and
threw it across the
river and I took off my coat and threw
it across the
river
I took off my sack and threw it across
the
river I had to jump and
land I had to land well sort of like
Spider-Man in today's Marvel
movies so back then we fearlessly set
off for a place where we could die while
crossing the
river but we arrived at the temple
safely and my friend left two days later
and I stayed there for about a
month it was so deep in the mountains
that no one ever really came
by
it was in short in the middle of nowhere
where it was hard to see even one person
for an entire
year and one day we ran out of rice so
my senior monk had to leave for the
village to get
some she left early in the morning and
told me she'd be back by noon
and I was left all alone in the
temple when noon came and I was in the
kitchen scooping up some rice for lunch
when I suddenly felt that there was
someone behind
me
you know it was kind of that Eerie
feeling and my nerves were very on
edge so I slowly turned around as if
nothing was the matter and I looked
back and I saw three or four strangers
very big men standing in front of the
door
now this was a place where nobody ever
came to but these people were snake
catchers they looked at me and said
please give us some
water
now there were no houses around the
Hermitage so back then we used to drink
directly from a nearby stream so I gave
them a gourd and told them that's what
they should do as
well after drinking the water the men
thanked me and
left as soon as they disa appeared I
felt an immense wave of fear come over
me and I started
trembling I ran into the Dharma Hall and
I latched all the doors and I put a
Korean style spoon onto the door handle
to latch
it
I was so afraid that I hid myself in the
innermost corner of the room because I
was scared of my shadow being visible if
I was near the door which was made of
paper I pulled the blanket over myself
and trembled my heart was racing and I
was so scared that I couldn't think of
anything I forgot my hunger and the need
to eat and was completely unaware of the
time
passing
fear took over my entire body and the
senior monk who said she'd be back by
now still hadn't returned and I just
stayed there shaking with fear and
before I knew it the sun had set and it
was
evening it was 1981 so we didn't have
any electricity in those mountains
and it started to get get dark outside
the
window I had not done anything for half
a day because I was so overwhelmed with
fear but at that moment a thought
occurred to
me
it was like a light bulb lighting up
brightly in the
dark it had been a long time since those
people had gone so why am I still
scared what is it that I'm afraid
of
the moment this thought occurred my fear
completely
disappeared the world became clear as if
a veil had been
lifted it was then when I was 21 years
old that I realized my fear was in my
thoughts and in my
heart
to be more precise it was my mind that
was creating the
fear only then did I finally pull up
pull back the blankets I got up and I
saw the moonlight shining into the room
through my window and when I saw this my
mind felt at
ease do you remember that spoon I
latched to the door handles I removed
the spoon opened the door and came out
of the
room
how can I even explain this feeling this
was in the middle of summer but when I
went out into the yard the Moonlight was
so white it was as if white snow had
covered the entire
yard there was also a pine tree in the
yard and its shadow was was swaying in
the
wind and so I wrote a few lines about
what I felt in that moment which later
became the lyrics to a song called windy
Hermitage Wendy Hermitage you probably
didn't even know this song
existed of course not
right
number the funny thing is this song
became the most popular song among
Korean Buddhists for 30 years isn't that
surprising honestly I don't really know
how that
happened the lyrics of this song capture
the fear that froze me and my youth as
well as the realization that came in the
moment that I broke free from
it
it was the first time that I truly
understood that I am the one creating
the fear and that I am the only one who
can recognize and overcome
this this is the first few lines of the
song should I sing
it
[Music]
foree
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
so I just sang A first few lines of the
song and I know that nowadays this may
not be your cup of
tea we think we know our own minds but
in reality we really
don't I can't throw my
mind and that is why I wrote these words
I can't draw my
mind and perhaps the same goes for
fear fear is an emotion that we feel
instinctively in the process of caring
for and protecting
ourselves you may have heard of this but
in neuros science the area of the brain
that triggers the flight response in our
moments of fear is called the amydala
we need this in order to take care of
ourselves
properly however when this fear becomes
excessive it overwhelms
us then we see nothing but
fear when the moment of fear passes
there is no need to dwell on it any
longer when a gazelle sees another
gazelle being eaten by a a cheetah it
may be very shocked in that moment but
after that moment passes it will not
dwell on that fear it will move
on the same is true of good things as
well because we can't remain perpetually
in a state of
excitement whether it is fear or
something we like what we need is
something called attention
recovery when something happens you
should focus your attention on it but
when it's resolved you should withdraw
that
attention but many people find this
difficult recovering your attention from
if whatever is making you afraid or
whatever is making you
[Music]
happy for example when you feel a
negative emotion towards someone else
you will continue to pour your energy
into
it you think about it when you get home
and sometimes even dream about it and
that is where you pour all your energy
into if you don't recover your attention
you will continue to drain your
energy and that's probably why people
get so tired so easily
lately when something bad happens
there's no use in asking why this
happened let's say that a tornado comes
and blows your house
away no one can answer the question of
why your house was blown away while the
house next door was
fine
it is important not to dwell on why
these things happen but to think about
what steps you should take next and
focus your attention on resolving the
situation in this respect life is just
like a
game we sometimes ask questions like why
was I born and blame our parents or our
society for things that happened to
us but there is no answer to the
question of why we are
born the moment we are born The Game of
Life
Begins once the game has started you
need to live and act by the rules of the
game all we can do is think about how to
do our best with what we've been already
given if we enter the playing field and
the ball comes flying in our direction
we need to catch it quickly and pass it
on to someone else instead of asking
questions like why is the ball flying
towards
me we can't be asking questions like
what am I supposed to do with this
ball so when the game begins don't just
look around start
moving
play depending on the stage of your life
the rules and the playing grounds will
continue to
change and we just need to continue
playing according to our
rules just because we lose one game
doesn't mean your life is
over you will always get another chance
and that is
life from the moment we are born we grow
as we
age but there are two paths in
life one is a horizontal path and the
other is a vertical
path
the horizontal path is a life that
progresses laterally as one ages through
infancy adolescence youth adulthood and
old
age the word horizontal here means that
although you may grow older in age you
remain on the same level only moving
from side to
side this path is living a life full of
sensuality and distrust desire and
[Music]
anger on the other hand the vertical
path is a life in which you grow by
actively leaping upwards through infancy
adolescence youth adulthood and old
age and this path becomes filled with
the exploration of
life in this kind of life you get older
and you gain more experience and you are
not easily
swayed
rather a life becomes more beautiful
with each passing
year just because you lose once doesn't
mean everything is
over you'll always get another chance
even if this one
passes that is
life so believe in
yourself and you also need to love
yourself don't forget that you are the
main character of this life remember
life is on your side thank you for
listening my story thank you so
much
[Applause]
oh
okay any questions
should we end this if there are no
further
questions
yes for people who aren't um monastics
but who are practicing Buddhism um how
do you think we can most meaningfully
make that a part of our life um when we
have uh so many distractions and so many
pressures put upon us to um especially
in like a university keep up with other
statuses of uh status and uh career and
all of
that
for
[Music]
so I don't think there's a separate path
that practitioners need to take it
doesn't matter if you're in a temple or
a university what matters is what you do
in your current situation what you
decide at your
mind
um I was very captivated by by your
thoughts
about attention control and
retaining regaining attention control
and I think it's particularly important
in digital times when when we are so so
much engaged and being engaged uh in
into giving away our attention in this
economy of attention um for those who do
not practice just ordinary us are there
any ways you could uh tell us to
function better in under these
circumstances thank
[Music]
you
good
question
so you don't need to practice Buddhism
in order to control yourself your life
we all want to live a better life and
the reason why we consume so much
information is because we want to know
more and what's really important here is
to turn your attention to your inner
self we need to take we need to discard
of the labels like oh Buddhist
practitioner whether we are Buddhist
practitioners or not the important thing
is to turn and look at your inside your
inner self for
example
um computer
come
so when you're looking at information on
a computer try to be aware of the very
Act of looking on the screen and think
about who is looking at what the subject
and the object of the Gaze and try to
think try to focus on what exactly is it
that I want to gain from this
information do you play a lot of online
games then you have nothing to worry
about
yes um I've been uh practicing Buddhism
for a few years not as much as I would
like to but I have um found it very
important to be very present in the
moment and I found that active that
active practice takes effort um and I
very much appreciate what you said in
your story but in today's society when
we have the conflicts we have with
Israel and
Hamas I want to be present in the moment
but I also want to respect what is
happening and to consider that so how do
you reconcile those two um
you know I obviously have to live and
and go throughout the day but I feel for
the people so
much oh yes yes
yes
yeah May the victims rest in peace
yeah a war is not something that should
ever
happen and we have been through so many
wars throughout history
but we still haven't learned from
it is because of foolishness and
ignorance even if there are personal or
national benefits through war that
nothing is more important than
life
we won't be able to stop War through
anger being angry and wanting Revenge
will you can't stop it with more
anger you can only end anger with
compassion
but when war is happening we all feel
pain for the
victims but what we really need to focus
on in that
moment we need to be focusing on what we
can do in our current
situation Boven continued to compose
music during World War II even when
bullets were flying over his
head and War reporters know that there
is a very real chance of death but
they're still there in the thick of
it no matter all the terrible things
that happen in this world we need to be
aware of where we are and what we need
to do it's okay thank
you
thank you for sharing
okay uh thank you so much for your time
today I think we uh all really
appreciate it my question was uh in your
experience what is the most effective
way to learn about
Buddhism you talking
okay are you interested in
Buddhism do you
like do you like Buddhism
Buddhism yes thank
[Music]
you it's very simple to the easiest way
of knowing Buddhism in your everyday
life is very
simple make others happy the way you
want to be
happy just like you want to avoid pain
avoid inflicting pain on others that's
it um thank you hi um first of all thank
you so much for your lovely talk and
your story um I just wanted to ask a
question about um we covered a little
bit about fear um and in especially here
in the west we have um whether it's the
the media industry there's a there's a
profit there's like a Prof profiting off
of fear there's a utilization of fear
systematically to whether it's to divide
people or to you know fund or create
support for Wars you know um get in the
face of this systemic rise of Fear not
only individually within people but like
from institutions itself how do you
think we should take a more systematic
approach to tackle this growing rampant
fear
yeah ah very difficult
question I mean I can't do much about it
yeah
but what I would like to say is don't be
too swayed by all the information that
you receive from the
outside the outside is just the outside
whether it's the media the
news you need to be firm and not Swit
elephants don't fall even when they
receive a lot of
arrows your inner self you need to be
firm so even if there is a war going on
on our side if you maintain peace and
calmness within yourself and everybody
sort of contributes to that we will be
able to contribute to the
world thank you for thinking about the
world hi thank you very much um I'm
going to relay this in English because I
don't know how to say this in Korean
um um I'm really captivated by the the
concept of attention reset and attention
recovery um but really what are some
what are the best ways to apply that in
moments of of joy and happiness um I I
think that's something that I'm still
trying to understand is is kind of you
know moments of fear moments of of of of
um you know just of trouble and
challenges I understand and I think like
just it's in our nature to it's in my
nature to you know want to have a apply
that attention recovery but I'm I'm just
trying to figure out how I can apply
that moments of of joy as
well when we're happy and joyful we want
to stay that
way
but in reality if you think about it
it's harder to recover your attention in
moments of
fear and if you're unlucky you could it
could Alo lead to
death and even joyful things things that
make you happy if it's in excess it
could also lead to
death mindful
[Music]
so in Buddhism we practice
mindfulness and the reason for that is
to avoid these two
extremes there's no good no bad if we
put an end to those two
extremes we'll be able to know that joy
and fear
neither are
Eternal um I really appreciated that
analogy about life being a game and when
you get thrown a ball you just have to
catch it quickly and throw it to someone
else um but practically what does that
mean I think it's very easy as college
students especially to get stuck in the
question of like what do I do with this
ball so how do we know to just throw
it are you a college student
[Music]
okay so when people are born we have 800
bones in our
body
and as we grow they fuse into fuse with
each other to form 206 bones by the age
of
30 so for our brains between the ages of
25 to 30 the neurons our neurons will be
covered by this thing called
myelin and you haven't got to that stage
yet you're still
growing don't be afraid to explore and
make
mistakes go through a lot of trials and
tribulations the most interesting in
life is about the
trials look at sports athletes they go
through a lot of trouble and then before
finally winning that gold medal
don't be afraid of the waves that come
at
you when you're afraid tell yourself
that it's okay and everything will
pass and this is something that I
mentioned at the Buddhist student
Community event that we had
yesterday in America we have the
National
Park and when I went there 20 years ago
there were so many trees that were 2,000
5,000 years
old and I bought a seed
there and the seed was very very
[Music]
small I put it on top of my fingernails
and I rubbed it and it was just gone
Without a
Trace but imagine that great tree all
started from the tiniest
seeds when you feel worried you feel
that you are very
small
but there is a great tree waiting to
grow inside of you and you are that kind
of seed no
problem don't worry about
it please remember go through those
trials and tribulations and keep
[Music]
exploring it is the best part of life
and it's great for you to grow as a
person
I I went through a lot of trouble after
being ordained but that's made me into
who I am
today I became a nun at
16 what what could I have known at that
age I told them that I would bear
whatever burden that comes my
way
hi thank you uh again for coming and
speaking to us today um I also had a
question about the game of um how you
describe the Game of Life um what would
you say to someone who might like be
tired of The Game of Life and not really
want to like keep
playing um yeah I I think that's
it
that is one decision you can
make but if we have to make that
decision among all the options wouldn't
it be better to choose the option to
keep continue playing that game
of course you might feel like you don't
want to do
anything and and it's okay not to do
something at the
moment that's not a problem when it
comes to
life are you personally sort of troubled
by that kind of stuff uh no one of my
friends
is
would you be able to share more about
that kind of feeling yeah I mean um like
they often tell me that it's like you
like kind of go through things and you
don't really know why you're doing
everything and um like if it would just
be better to like stop playing the game
of Life
yeah
there are a lot of young people nowadays
who think the same
things there are so many in
Korea perhaps we think about those kinds
of things because the world has become a
better place to live in
there is no particular meaning to
life we create our own
meanings you need to be able to put in
the effort to create that
meaning and you want to help your friend
through this yeah of
course
sometimes that thing those kind of
things arise out of a sense of
superiority or
inferiority but in reality there's no
one who's like better than us or worse
than
us
does your friend take any kind of like
medication for that stuff uh no no
okay maybe you can suggest
meditation do you think they'll be
interested in that um I honestly I don't
think so
but what about sports
no then there's nothing I can
say so you gave me a very good question
and I'd like to introduce a book by a
Yale Professor called Mark
Brad PR PR
to feel permission to feel permission to
feel uh this is by Professor Mark
bracket of Yale University and it's also
been translated into
Korean I was very moved after reading
this book and I met the professor
earlier
today
it hasn't been long since we've been
living with our emotions and we've
actually lived for a long time without
feeling those kinds of
emotions apparently emotions as we know
have only been in existence for the past
15,000
years
depression anxiety fear all these
emotions are in reality what humans have
created for
themselves so that means we can also
learn to control those
emotions and this book sort of explains
those kind of techniques that we can use
to control those emotions and it's been
a great great help to
me and I would very much like to
recommend this book to you
all thank you so much for sharing your
lovely story
um you mentioned that we should choose
to grow vertically um as opposed to
horizontally as we age from infancy
through old age and my question to you
is what are we growing
towards um so to put it differently in
Buddhist teachings what is considered a
good life um
before you end your
life have you studied or know anything
about
Buddhism uh I'm not a practitioner but I
am very much
interested
[Music]
okay so Buddhism suggests two
things
so what's difference the difference
between animals and humans that we have
that ability to perceive and understand
things and that's why we put it the
effort for our own personal
growths and that's why we also help
others to achieve their own growths
so we learn about both of these things
learning from the growing for ourselves
and helping others grow in
Buddhism so this term grow is actually
used in English circles and it's not a
term that we use in
Buddhism and I just use the term growing
to make it easier to
understand in Buddha we teach that each
of us are our own
Buddhas Buddha isn't something that
exists outside the Buddha is in within
all of
us but we tend to think of ourselves and
the Buddha as
separate and so we continue looking for
the
Buddha but in reality we are the Buddha
sitting right here
okay
finishing
okay um thanks for all the sharing I
think I just have a simple question so
after practice is saying Buddhism for so
many years what do you look forward to
every
day very nice question
yes so when I became a
monk
do you
know so I was very enamored about the
vows made in
Buddhism
and I was very enamored by all the great
teachings that I had never even seen in
school so there is a vow in Buddhism
where I want to be the medicine for
someone who is
ill and there is a vow that where I want
to become a bridge or a boat for someone
who is trying to cross a
river so when I see these vows I feel
very
moved the fact that I can be this kind
of person and the fact that I am that
kind of
person
so when I pray every morning I pay my
respects to those great
teachings to those beautiful teachings
okay thank you thank you so much yeah I
um I have one more
question
yes uh okay I don't know the maybe I can
you know explain is exactly you not but
I'm Korean is moved to the here littleit
more than 20 years ago when I came here
I saw your profile then the one of your
um the name of the book uh
more uh getting more empty you can get
more food something like that
right
for
so the question was about how do you
empty yourself because when he read uh
one of um Sim's books uh he and he was
very captivated by the title because the
title is the more you empty the Fuller
it gets and when he received his Dharma
name in Korea his Dharma name means
emptiness and so he tried reading the
flower Garland Sutra but it was too hard
and he couldn't read it and he still
doesn't really know how to empty
yourself and the question was about that
okay have you heard of the G Theory no
okay so in the night sky when we see
stars we say that the stars are
twinkling
but in reality we're not looking at the
stars we're looking at a dark night
sky we need that dark night sky in order
to see the
stars you can't separate the stars from
the dark
sky and there is hatred because there is
love and there are farewells because
there are
encounters we have this because there is
that and
other and that is
Buddhism and to know that is to know
Emptiness is this very
easy yes thank you on that not please
give
her
thank you thank you so much thank
[Music]
you